antiguo camillero y luego auxiliar de
enfermería
cristian está ahora en formación para
convertirse en enfermero pero realiza su
práctica de segundo año como apoyo de
auxiliar de enfermería en el servicio de
reanimación en el hospital de arriondas
y actualmente tengo una especie de doble
personalidad soy estudiante de segundo
año y al mismo tiempo soy auxiliar de
enfermería es también nuestro deber ser
útiles para el hospital pero de todas
maneras se sentía un poco de temor
porque pensé que aún seguía en formación
entonces es posible que tenga más
lagunas en ciertas cosas pero
seguramente voy a aprender mucho más por
haber tenido que adaptarme rápidamente a
las situaciones a pesar de estos ajustes
ligados a la epidemia de kobe 19
cristian adquiere nuevas competencias
gracias a su asignación al cargo con
frecuencia a los pacientes en
reanimación están entubados entonces no
pueden comer solos los alimentamos y los
hidratamos a través de una máquina en
reanimación esta tarea le compete a la
auxiliar de enfermería nunca lo había
hecho antes y desde ayer estoy
aprendiendo a hacerlo en francia- el 80%
de los estudiantes de enfermería fueron
movilizados durante
la primera ola al igual que cristian
muchos de ellos como auxiliares de
enfermería un oficio que oficialmente
pueden ejercer al final de su primer año
de estudios
el reto para los institutos de formación
es mantener la continuidad pedagógica en
su totalidad
hicimos algo particular porque en cada
pasantía los estudiantes tienen una
fecha de evaluación donde están
detalladas todas las competencias y
luego son evaluadas en realidad
traducimos estas competencias a esta
crisis en particular
y en efecto no podríamos planificar los
tres años de formación bajo este modelo
porque realmente dejaría muchas lagunas
más allá de la formación práctica el
reto es ante todo preservar el bienestar
de los estudiantes y su salud mental
durante el periodo más crítico de la
primavera hubo un acompañamiento casi
cotidiano por parte de los formadores
que llamaban a los estudiantes para
escucharlos y para saber qué había
pasado
se reunieron con los estudiantes en
lugares tanto de día como de noche y a
distancia se implementaron algunos
grupos de apoyo moderados por psicólogos
del hospital con los cuales trabajamos
son células psicológicas a las que se
accede de manera desigual dejando a
muchos estudiantes aislados y otros
llegan hasta abandonar por completo
armand por su parte decidió no seguir
con su formación después de su
experiencia en el centro hospitalario y
universitario de estrasburgo una de las
regiones más afectadas por la primera
ola cada vez que volvía había pacientes
que habían muerto durante la noche
por lo general hacemos cuidados post
morten para un paciente aquí lo metemos
en una bolsa y dejábamos el cuerpo en la
morgue pasaba con frecuencia que me
sentaba en mi carro solo para llorar y
para tratar de no mostrarlo porque al
final lo que vivimos también es un
trauma
asignado también a un puesto como
auxiliar de enfermería en calidad de
practicante la región de gran este le
había prometido a estos estudiantes una
gratificación de mil trescientos euros
al mes pero ammán recibió su sueldo por
pedazos y sus horas suplementarias no se
le pagaron estaba ahí como auxiliar de
enfermería era el único auxiliar del
servicio y no estaba en formación estaba
ahí para trabajar y para trabajar muy
barato
para hablar de manera concreta el primer
mes recibí 1100 euros y el segundo a 900
euros aunque era el segundo mes que
encadenaba tres semanas de trabajo de 50
horas cada uno en la federación nacional
de los estudiantes de enfermería la
situación es preocupante antes de la
crisis sanitaria un cuarto de los
aprendices de enfermería había
abandonado su formación antes de
terminar el objetivo del seguro de la
sanidad firmado en julio pasado era
revalorizar el estatuto de los
enfermeros a largo plazo el subsidio
para los estudiantes en cuidados de
enfermería por fuera de los periodos de
crisis pasó a doscientos euros al mes es
decir tres veces menos que para los
estudiantes de la universidad un monto
insuficiente para la presidenta del
sindicato parece como si el gobierno se
estuviera burlando de nosotros y que se
acordará que existimos solo cuando se
necesitan ayudantes actualmente se está
poniendo en peligro la profesión porque
en unos años nadie querrá dedicarse a
este oficio si la situación siga así
louis estudiante de segundo año ha hecho
dos pasantías como refuerzo por kobe
ahora debe contentarse con unos cursos
virtuales han tenido labores técnicas
aparte de la pcr desde hace más de ocho
meses al final de nuestros tres años
tendremos un verdadero diploma de
aprendizaje no pondremos en peligro a
nuestros pacientes
para seguir ayudando a los pacientes a
pesar de todo
louis se apoyó en su pasión la música
ya no había familia para los pacientes
no podían recibir visitas tampoco había
nada que los animará de tocar muy poco
el piano pero a veces le cantaba a los
pacientes cuando tenía una pausa eso me
hacía bien me permitía darme un respiro
era como una escapatoria ante la crisis
sanitaria y a pesar de los retrasos
acumulados los 96 mil estudiantes de
enfermería de francia se acordarán por
mucho tiempo de este año 2020 y del
apoyo vital que le aportaron a los
hospitales
será más peligroso